Selene schema thank you
okay I thought it would be cool if this
lecture had a title and I think it's
gonna be ready for the rising tide I
hope this is English you tell me but I'm
not sure of that title yet
and we'll see as we go along because yes
I'm still in the process of writing this
pitch and that's because and I'm being
honest here and it's totally my fault
not at all your fault I discovered about
this lecture four days ago I'd said yes
to come here to meet you for weeks but I
just thought it was classic your knife
which will also be so it's okay I'm
really bad it's okay the letter
mentioning the term lecture took weeks
to actually arrive to me it arrived four
days ago so it's not because I didn't
take things seriously that I mean that I
am in that position I care a lot about
this invitation from the BAFTAs in a
tremendous 2019 and Beyond lineup and I
care a lot about being invited by the
British industry written about by
British critics and meeting the British
audience because you people here get my
job the most here I feel deeply
understood supported and I am personally
fragile eyes by the fact that you would
leave Europe and I'm telling you French
people are gonna hate missing you so
four days ago I read the letter
describing this performance and there
were links of previous lectures so I
clicked and I was immediately frightened
because of this this because I saw this
this is scary
imagine offering this as a gift to
people for Christmas and wrapping it
they would be scared like what do you
want from me
anybody super happy to get this would be
label as suspect because it is scary
this puts you in a position of solitude
and in the position where you have to
stand for something it might be the only
object that embodies that and also that
puts you in the presidential mood like -
mic stand makes you Freddy laughs Korean
so with this podium a word that I
learned yesterday as lecture I
understood that I had the opportunity to
say something about screenwriting in
front of you today and now I needed to
find what because I think a lot of
things about screenwriting in fact I
believe I am a screenwriter because I
like asking myself questions about
screenwriting I do this job to have the
opportunity to reflect and be part of
the invention the defense the politics
of writing for cinema but I don't have a
big synthesis a formulated theory maybe
it's time that I tried would you here
and now
I guess explaining how I write so far
has always been in contradiction with
the fact that I believe that my movies
should be prototypes and invent their
own language still this argument doesn't
stand because even within an
experimental dynamic you still have to
find a way of doing it a method or
process for searching and finding the
ideas the paradox is that you have to
find your method because you don't need
one at least you don't feel you need one
as a screenwriter and somebody pitches
you something or when you think freely
about a plot ideas come in very fast you
really find some narrative arcs
obstacles this scene where this
character who I mean in hours minutes
sometimes I'm sure screenwriters in the
room know that feeling very well there
is no blank page syndrome at the
beginning of writing because it's a job
it's craft with tools for building
stories
and it's a thrilling sensation
screenwriters know how to write and
sometimes this might be our biggest
problem because this knowledge comes
from a culture of storytelling I think
writing is all about questioning that
that's why you need a method I do have
my way of doing it I guess at that stage
I could drop a central notion here
desire to me writing is about having
desires for IDs therefore it is always
about trying to build an architecture of
multiple desires the word desire is
traditionally linked to cinema that has
long been called the industry of desire
this idea is polemical on a lot of
levels in 2019 if you want my opinion
but it is our culture the one we grew up
in at least yet desire isn't a word we
associate with screen what else are
words it is associated with the idea of
images and making images as a writer you
are only asked about desire as an
initial spark that puts you at work the
desire to write that story or in a more
introspective introspective
psychoanalytic question the desire under
the story your secret desire it is
pretty rare that you get to refer to
your present desire or a desire building
up also because the process of writing
is so long it's like it doesn't have a
present because it is constituted of
layers and layers and it's all about
rewriting but to me that's actually the
point the fact that screenwriting is the
opportunity to work on your desires
rather than acting immediately on them
here I must say that putting desire at
the center isn't about making it organic
or personal that would be feminine and
despised it is to make it sharp and
uncompromising it is about the
construction and being radical with
yourself not self-indulgent at all it's
about resisting easy pleasures and
resisting the temptation of belonging
at that point I'm sure this feels quite
abstract mostly because desire doesn't
feel reliable as a method desire doesn't
even have the repetition to be accurate
can we trust someone desires it seems
like a very vast and mysterious feeling
or sensation but make no mistake it's
not because it's white it's because it
is hitting hard somewhere and having a
stronger Iko Iko rising tide I might say
and that leaves a chance to that title
I think desire is super accurate but you
have to locate it my job as a
screenwriter is to work on locating that
place where desire is precisely hitting
for myself if I write for myself or for
my colleague director if I were writing
for somebody it's about finding the
point of impact and get accurate about
what you want rather than think of
desire as a romantic mystery about
yourself so there's three steps the
first step is identifying and locating
your global desires for film
understanding them and be honest about
them this takes time because there are
several impacts on different zones
political desire aesthetic desire
production desire you have to locate
them and trust them enough to
deconstruct them for portrait of a lady
on fire I had several big desires for
instance that once located where
designing the map of the film I wanted
to write the present of a love story how
it is born and how it grows patiently
but I also wanted to tell about the
memory of a love story what is left of a
love story
both these levels were equally designed
and not compromising means crafting the
storytelling that would allow both
dynamics I wanted to show an artist at
work and write an artist model
collaboration that would depart from the
fetishized mused tradition I wanted it
to be a period piece but tied budgeted
because I didn't want it to be dusty and
meticulous and mundane I wanted it to be
a contemporary form even those that
in the past those desires are mostly
political as you can see and it can seem
a little bit cold but political desire
for the film is also at the heart of the
decision to actually write it because it
will be about finding hot solution to
these theoretical desires and there
starts the second step the second step
is about working on a local level which
means the scene the scenes are at the
center of my writing process each scene
as a unit of desire technically this is
how it works
it is about having two files opened on
my laptop to list the first list is very
free it's a list of ideas for scene
sometimes just images a line of dialogue
they have no connections one with
another and often not connection yet
with the plot of the film for portrait
of a lady on fire my first list was list
was Via della Nell run fast towards the
edge of a cliff actually setting fire to
the character an abortion being painted
a group of women singing an unknown tune
in the night a sentence don't regret
remember and the last scene of the film
a long take on a character listening to
V Valdez summer in a concert hall those
are the desired scene the ones you don't
have to look for there are your compass
the ones you make the film for those
belong to the list of scenes you desire
they have their point of impact
sometimes you don't even know why you
just know that they will be in the film
and you should respect that a lot the
other file is a list of scene you need
the steps that are inevitably building
the story the ones that are logically
unfolding your pitch or plot that list
goes like this the scene when the
painter is commissioned by the mother
the scene where the painter arrives at
the castle the scene where the painter
assists the sitter for the first time to
see what the painter starts to paint
the seed with the sitter discovers a
portrait - seen what that mate gets an
abortion I'm going I'm going to all the
film like that those scenes seems much
more simpler to actually write because
they belong they are needed but actually
my work is all about making them belong
to the other list they must become
desired every single one of them my rule
is that not a single scene must stay on
the needed list because it's cinema
everything and then I'm not gonna direct
it everything you write will have 20
people working on it so that means
hundreds of questions you are going to
have to answer some of them will seem
pointless but you can't leave one single
question unanswered your absence of
choice will have an impact so for
instance I can take the example of a
simple scene that is a very simple
breathing moment in the films the three
women the painter the center and the
servant are in the kitchen - silence
Eloise is making dinner Sophie is doing
embroidery and Mayon serving some red
wine writing the scene is five lines
making the scene is answering - what
time of the day is it what's the weather
like what is the menu what shade in
shape of plates do you want where should
the glass be stored looking at plans of
the table will be it's also give the
actress lessons of embroidery design
your embroidery weeks before with an
artist if the scene is not important to
you it will get the same amount of
questions so you have to want every
scene very deeply it is about caring you
have to care about every detail so
nothing should stay in the list of the
scenes that you need every scene has to
have its own desire well then the
biggest job is thinking strongly about
each scene in that need list and find
something that hits you accurately which
means deeply this take most of my time
in the writing process because I don't
actually start writing the continuity of
the script until those two files become
one
the painter will arrive by boat and jump
into the water to save a canvas the
model will surprisingly be critical when
she sees a portrait for the first time
rather than intimidated the abortion
scene will take place with the baby
sharing the frame with the character
terminating a pregnancy sometimes you
don't find an idea that you have a
strong desire for because sometimes a
scene is about getting from a place to
another what do you do then I used to
think useful scenes should at least be
shot for editing hypotheses but now I
don't anymore I am being radical with
this belief at the stage of my fourth
film I decided to get rid of the scenes
which had been sticking for too long in
the needed list I just erased them it
puts you in a position when you now have
two scenes you want without the bridge
of the scene you need but it actually
produces editing within the script and
confronts you to new narratives or
rhythm makes you be more experimental
new power dynamics between the
characters it actually helps you be
brave and depart from the comforts of a
solution that has been tested that works
and that feels reassured it makes you
depart from convention the hot part of
that process is that when you go along
with the convention and the rules of
storytelling you feel you are writing it
looks like you're writing because it's
efficient and understood it takes a
strong will to go deep you have to
accept the fact that you are choosing
and satisfaction for a while you are not
writing you are thinking about writing
when the list is done on this one file I
start to write continuity in the
dialogues and I must say I don't work at
all thinking about character design it's
not part of my process I never think
about characters as fictional persons I
don't think about them out of the
timeline and the context of the scenes
like what should she do how would she
think characters are never
this is I don't think about backstories
for them I don't even give them surnames
when I'm asked about the future of my
characters Ionis Leon said that they
don't exist
I don't think about their resume I just
know how they act and what they go
through in the present of the narrative
which means that here again I focus on
their desires the characters our desire
driven I think this method can be
applied to every type of films and
characters but I am pretty sure it is
linked to the fact that I'm writing
female-driven
stories women have been objectified by
fiction and by the patriarchal low
throughout history so giving them back
their subject status their subjectivity
is giving them back their desires
heroines don't have the same
opportunities as heroes to have project
freedom fiction is not a safe space for
female characters they don't get rid of
oppression there you can't artificially
free women in fiction so if you want to
tell their stories it's not about when
they live because they rarely have the
opportunity to live fully especially in
a period piece which is practical it's
about what they experienced portrait
ability on fire only looks and tell
about its characters desires because
they don't have to think the freedom to
project themselves so it's about how
their desire will be fulfilled for a
moment desire is females opportunity for
fiction and at that stage maybe I could
change the title of the lecture two
female gays at the stage of
screenwriting can't you think so
technically even though portrait can be
pitched as an impossible love story it
is not written that way it only tells
about the possible love their experience
of it it's not about their relationship
facing the world and the rules it's
about the two of them facing each other
of course the story is impossible but
their love isn't oh is know isn't isn't
the love is possible so I decided not to
tell about the obstacles the enemies the
traps men leave the impossibility out of
the room because it would be waiting for
them anyway when they get out if you
take a moment to think about it this big
rule that we totally follow that telling
about the obstacles between the
characters desire and its fulfillment
would be more interesting and valuable
than telling about the desire itself is
weird but this is how we learn
screenwriting as the art of conflicts
and that leads us to the third and final
step of this process once you have all
your scenes as a list of strong desire
and local solutions you then have your
narrative and you can actually read your
film and go back to this global scale at
that moment you have the opportunity to
fully see and understand the desire you
have for the narrative you now see a
pattern in the addition of the all the
local desires you found in the scenes
that tell you about your higher desire
your desire for storytelling your
reflection on cinema for portrait it
appeared quite clearly the desire was to
break the narrative of conflict and once
you make the diagnosis you should go for
it all the way in going all the way with
the script was writing a love story
based on equality breaking this
narrative of conflict was made possible
by the fact that it is two women meeting
so there is no gender domination and
then I decided that there will also be
no intellectual domination even though
it's an artist and a model and also
never to play with social hierarchy
those decision are hard to take because
we are born and raised in cinema being
thought that conflict is the natural
dynamic of the storytelling and that a
good scene is in a way a good bargain
between characters so no conflict boring
I got the best free player while in camp
so maybe but also I guess not
lack of conflict doesn't mean lack of
tension lack of conflict doesn't mean
lack of eroticism lack of conflict
actually means new rhythm because of a
dialogue not built of bargaining
lack of conflict actually means new
power dynamic that allows surprises and
new suspense that's what is at stake in
a story with equality actually equality
brings unconventional power dynamic to
the screen so basically as a viewer you
don't know what's going to happen which
is the basis of being both entertained
and committed to a story I'm going to
end this by trying to embody this whole
reflection into one example so there was
a scene on the list of the needed scene
the first kiss scene I needed to fill
that with an idea that I will feel
strongly about and that you would feel
strongly about a desire that would
actually talk about desire so I began a
list of first kiss situation and ideas I
think in mind that a good first kiss
scene is about the choreography that
will lead you to it that's what you
remember for first kiss more than
anything and also having in mind that a
good first kiss scene must feel new it
must feel like a first time like if I
try to think about who did really well
in the last few years
Spider Man comes to mind a spider-man in
French the backward kiss really badly
I have no clips there was an idea an
idea that felt new because it engaged
both characters in another dynamic of
power I'm obsessed with this we are not
sure what it is but it does feel
different and it's unforgettable so it
is a good first kiss scene I also wanted
to challenge politically the kissing
scene we traditionally either either
have the surprise kissing thanks to a
rain shower for instance are the obvious
kiss scene thanks to mustard on the
corner of the lips for instance and it
is generally carefully scripted as the
kiss or the passionately kissing and
then it's on ReactOS shoulders it seems
to realize a lot endure on them for sure
because it's their bodies and fluids
interaction but it shouldn't be it's
fake it's not about finding the magic
actors should always be part of the
elaboration of an idea especially with
intimate scenes so I wanted to craft a
scene that would embody the sexiness of
consent here again working the narrative
people who are questioning the idea of
asking for consent in France did do
exist they are brave fighters from the
culture of French gallantry while saying
that asking for consent will not be sexy
it will break the mood some of the
French critics for the film lacked flesh
I quote precisely because today emeritus
ism is about conflict I wish some daddy
would explain to me why in life being
kissed by surprise feels weird and
clumsy whereas hearing do you want me to
kiss you feels like being in a film
anyway at some point I came up with the
idea of them having to invade their
mouth like they wouldn't dress
themselves so I put a scarf scarf
justified by a strong wind pressed on
their lips thinking you would see their
heavy breathing through the moving
clothes let's watch it now please
did you do something if you know I
wasn't there
she'll have it wrong
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that wasn't a bachelors actually no
because I hadn't seen it tonight was it
because of the kitchen but I wanted to
make the bun to take the bonfire scene
also because well it kind of embodies
the kind of thing I've been telling you
like you see like their initial desires
these women singing in the night to an
unknown tune the character actually set
on fire the fact that there is no
bridges between these two scenes it's
just it's this hand thing and it's
another day and you and but we don't
need it we're trying not to use this nah
but bad so when you put so much desire
until it's seen you also have a strong
anticipation of the moment of shooting
it especially intimate things to go
smoothly to share cast care for your
cast that day came first we did the very
long traveling by the sea with their
hands touching and then it always
disappears and you find her in the
grotto we had trouble finding the right
way to do it we lost an hour so when we
began shooting the kissing scene I only
like had 15 minutes 15 minutes ahead of
me because the water was rising and
strong waves were already coming out of
fits so the shooting of this intimate
scene became five takes in a row with me
basically shouting at the actors from
the distance being totally frustrated
with strong waves coming closer reality
it's you hard in the process of shooting
a film it's about compromising so
knowing your priorities that's why you
mistake writing so seriously be radical
in screenwriting because if you are
radical with your desires in the scene
nothing will take it away and you will
always be ready for the rising tide
thank you
that rocket Thank You Celine thank you
so much for that and now my job now is
to just make you keep talking okay which
I'm very happy to do obviously having my
own personal Celine sciama Festival this
weekend and I would have said you were a
very instinctive filmmaker you you speak
from the heart but actually there's
something much more analytical about it
I don't think the heart is about
instinct it's like I'd like it's like I
said about desire I don't think it's
this thing that you know you should
analyze it I mean knowing your desire is
basically knowing your project and and
and speaking with the heart doesn't mean
like it's just it's that it's obvious
you still have to you have to work with
what you feel so that's why I'm saying
it's not cold I mean it's it's the
beginning when you write when you begin
to write it's super hot and then you
think about it becomes super cold and
then you have to find hot solutions to
cold ideas and it's about this oh yeah
this is this back and forth what about
the the structure part I mean it must be
quite hard when you've got you're sort
of fractured lists and you're trying to
put them into it into a kind of cohesive
narrative how are you is structure the
portrait is 69 sequences 69 scenes which
is very very few
I kind of have also these games of
because it's about the pace the rhythm
you want to create because it's two
hours and 69 scenes you got film and now
really how a film is usually 126 scenes
so it's also the I think a lot about
that that's what I'm looking for this
yeah this balance between the events and
the time we're gonna take looking at
those even the impact like how
everything has to be super meaningful
and and food and that's also why
sometimes I I try to mix different
scenes there's different ideas that you
know that would have could have created
five or six scene it's gotta be just one
like the bonfire scene for instance this
the fact that this them
let's take off her being pregnant and
then you get an abortion there's also
the love thing there's also this social
moment and it's a bridge to to love
finally happening being active so this
could be I mean those kind of fusion
have other synthesis of that's the kind
of things I'm looking for but it's not
about finding it and each time it's also
about finding a kind of pattern
sometimes you find things that just it
just and spreads all over the script
like for instance on the good example
for this one portrait is the Orpheus
dynamic there's this is there's a scene
in the film where they talk about they
read a few senior Smith and and they did
talk about the meaning of the story and
this is something that came very last in
the process of writing the script like
the script but I think was already we
already began financing with it but I
felt something was missing and I needed
the scene a next flick Netflix and
shield scene between the women so yeah
it's purely because I had them playing
cards and them drinking I want them to
talk about I want yeah I won't fiction
in their life because also the film is
about that it's about how art is an
education to love love is an education
to art and now fiction well you know and
so I thought okay deeply must read
something and I was thinking next
Netflix and chill and I was thinking
okay so it must be really like climatic
this was like this huge suspense and
some kind of things you can debate over
an obvious and you're it is it's perfect
for that because come on this is like
what why and then I discovered that I
discovered learned that it's a myth that
is actually really really criticized but
it's one of the myths that feminist
lectures have been playing with a lot
because he's actually about the male
gaze it's about like a man looking at a
woman basically killing her because he's
looking at her at the wrong moment bad
timing
and so I wanted them to talk about this
and to all that day there are policies
and what this idea of like yeah Marianne
sing like he's making the choice after
poet and not the choice of the lover
because he's trying is choosing a memory
rather than itself and and hello is
saying well maybe she said turnaround
maybe it's a decision so I kind of like
that thing and then and then like but
sometimes it happens like that like
frankly took two minutes I was like oh
my god this is gonna this is gonna be a
great thread in the whole script like
you just like that just happened I
thought oh I was looking for something
to do the link between those two
timelines I've been telling you about in
my amazing speech the present of in our
story end up and the memory of a love
story and this obvious thing was perfect
to actually connect those two timelines
so that's when the idea of Heloise ghost
appearing came for instance so it was
like and and that's also when in the end
she sees her for the last time and it's
this image has been hunted with and and
and every six turnaround so it's like
this whole obvious dynamic which is so
important in the film immini I think
some people like the film only for this
just came up like in this hotel room
intervene with you know just within five
minutes and that was it this afternoon
rather terrifying me I read an article
that's that way but in a press
conference about portrait where you said
I don't think I've got anything left to
say and I was paralyzed with fear that
you might not but you've relieved us all
we are gonna hear from you again thank
you so much this has been absolutely
[Applause]
[Music]
you